what the [ __ ] you gonna do greetings
from podcast Ville it's Wednesday June
the [ __ ] 10th the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by you ready for this I told you
manscape was announcing a new product
and I got it for you you ready the
scientists over at manscape have to
release their first [ __ ] nose hair
trimmer it's called the weed whacker let
me tell you some people there's four
things I care about okay I have to be
clean at all times that's my dick and
ball combo my [ __ ] my ears and my
nose I feel very self-conscious when I
leave the house and I see a [ __ ] long
hair coming out of my [ __ ] nose I
feel like stabbed myself in the face and
there's really nothing you ever get to
regular weed whackers the regular nose
trimmers you can't get in there gets a
couple hairs is I got cocaine [ __ ]
deep and grew the Cuban [ __ ] and pubic
[ __ ] hair in my nose it's tough to
cut the hairs from my nose manscaped has
changed that enough stuff out nose hair
with the best if you think manscape 3.0
is [ __ ] tremendous wait till you
[ __ ] try this nose trimmer you ready
for this clean the corona right out of
your [ __ ] nose when a q-tip glows and
that's gonna go in your [ __ ] eye
there's no more jungle in there 9,000
rpm motor and a blade that moves 360
degrees when you [ __ ] we whack your
nose everything comes out okay so do me
a favor right now we're gonna make an
introductory offer to you this is I used
it twice already
tremendous I'm gonna give you 20% off
and free shipping when you press him
like when you press in the special
clothes foot is it's called nose pubes
at man skin town you're never gonna get
this deal like this on nose candy anyway
I'm giving you 20% off and free shipping
at manscape com code nose pukes what the
[ __ ] you waiting for clean out your nose
stick a q-tip in you you take that old
[ __ ] well wax out wash your balls
clean you [ __ ] it's [ __ ] Wednesday
[ __ ] manscape com code nose pubes
kick this [ __ ] melee
[Music]
at the second stage we don't like
[ __ ] Malaysians family welcome to
church oh [ __ ] it's Wednesday
Oh Joey
so hundred degrees out they know
protestors out today
all the white people are home with the
air condition not even thinking about
african-americans there was three
protesters actually all of them were
black they got no way conditioner I said
[ __ ] it we ain't standing these four
walls will get knotty that's it once it
turns 100 degrees white protestors stay
home in the air conditioner emblem it's
all over
thank you very much for joining us this
morning let me tell you something by
Monday morning I get up whatever 6:00
I [ __ ] open up my computer I drink
some coffee I talked to my wife for a
couple of minutes and the first I I go
to Facebook and here's his just to let
you know about life guys this is why
sometimes I'm sorry I'm a little cynical
but it's all [ __ ] I opened up the
first [ __ ] message I have six
messages that morning Wow I'm a popular
guy ain't gonna look better [ __ ]
midnight I wake up at [ __ ] 6:00 like
on an hour a message an hour I open up
the [ __ ] message and so help me God
it's a [ __ ] thing that says I'll
never listen to your show again before
putting the [ __ ] [ __ ] on your show go
[ __ ] yourself now this is what I woke up
to this is Monday morning when you're
supposed to be the best you could be
some guy somewhere decided to wake up
Monday morning listen to the podcast
well not listen to it and say [ __ ] you
because I had a gay man on it's 2012
2020 you do know that and people are
marching outside for equality and here
this [ __ ] sends me back this message
now if this was two years ago I would
have said [ __ ] you you [ __ ] I'll
be the mother gets hit by a train I
didn't do that and just block them but
that just goes to let you know with all
the marches and all the equality and
everything people looking for listen I
didn't put everywhere on here to be
clueless
most people know these type of people
where we live they [ __ ] live here
because and they live here under the
controller everybody's beautiful we love
Polly we love this one we love death you
don't like nobody you know Marty okay I
love you people contact
be on your podcast and I never [ __ ]
you never [ __ ] I don't know who you
are and I say to you yet ring back
around or whatever listen to me and
listen to me good you know why we laugh
so hard on Monday on this podcast
because I love that kid with all my
heart when I go on the road in podcast
you people love it why because our
connection you can feel the love in here
that podcast is so good the other day
because I feel love for farik he's not a
friend of mine because I want to tell
the world I have a gay friend like most
people do with african-americans or gay
people they pick one and he's my best
friend they let everybody know they
invited him to that parties they always
have one black guy well it's just gonna
get called that from now on this shit's
over if you invite one you better have
20 then okay it's over stop it you're
bullshitting equal right see Martin
Luther King you don't know dick about
dick like I said to you with everything
going on in the world that's when I woke
up on a [ __ ] Monday morning was hate
so that's why I don't believe like all
right like I said on my tweet Thursday
or Wednesday
everything that changes from here on in
has to start from behind closed doors I
love Eric I didn't put every time
because he's [ __ ] gay well I'm not
friends and everybody's my my token gay
friend I love all game man I don't know
[ __ ] what you are yeah we talked about
Rani's we goof we have a good time but
hey I got respect for them and that's
just the way it goes and we don't like
gay people it's 2020 get over yourself
man get the [ __ ] over yourself I don't
know what else to tell you anyway we've
said today we're gonna review the
[ __ ] Bruce Lee thing but before we
brutal Bruce Lee thing we got a review
something else first but before we do
that respect Wednesday morning
it's 100 [ __ ] degrees I'm headed to
the beach tonight um saying oh yeah yeah
that's it why why we [ __ ] around
it's Beach weather fish and chips put a
blanket down going the ocean get some
[ __ ] water Corona there's gotta be
some top former Corona in the [ __ ]
water
yeah why not one of the kids got no
[ __ ] school I'm gonna do there's no
cap you I'm gonna sit around here I
don't like watching myself
I do not watch like this is lead up to
Bruce Lee I don't not like watching
myself on tape but a couple weeks ago
when we were gonna go back to I thought
I was gonna work last week June 4th and
5th without even thinking about it I one
night got high and started looking at
out of everything what I feel is the
best work I've ever done which is re
show this is not happening you know I
started watching the clips from there I
had never seen delay this one I did or
or would I never even watch it no I
never watched that one it's an and and
I'm how I when I clicked on so that I
realize there's a bunch of people
reviewing those so I started watching
some of the reviews and I was like wow I
didn't think that was powerful or
nothing I didn't think that would throw
somebody off like it did and bla bla bla
bla bla but I watched my tape and the
one I really paying attention to the one
that really [ __ ] with me the most is
me beaten up to nut the the thing about
me beating up the nun dog there was such
a [ __ ] up experience it was like many
of my experiences that I forgot all
about for years I had carried that
thought I never even thought about I
never know I mean it's something you do
that you're not proud of and you just
move on with your life and when all this
process started writing a book eight
years ago and [ __ ] I asked myself why
didn't why when I was in Boulder in 89
and I was confused after prison why did
I have to make my confidence and I got
confirmed when I was 29 is over 30 years
old why did I do that I was like why
don't I get confirm when I was a young
kid and I kept thinking about I'm like
oh my god that's right I was supposed to
make my confirmation that Sacred Heart
but before the fifth grade that's what I
after the figure I think you're making
confirmation in the sixth grade I got
thrown out in the fifth grade so all
that [ __ ] went down the tubes so it's
like your bar mitts so
tremendous I don't know what I'm smoking
they gave me something over [ __ ] now
urban trees that this [ __ ] curls your
[ __ ] eyebrow hair anyway so I'm
watching the one about I I told that
story the first time I don't want to
help in the Pajero girl in New York I
just came out how a fresco with it and
told us I wrapped the material around it
and told the story to the best of my
ability and it related because most of
the audience it was probably a 64%
Catholic and they've heard these stories
from their parents so I didn't really
know nothing of it I just thought it was
a joke and after I did like the first
two this is not happening
I already pulled me aside wooden bay
like the man that he is and he goes hey
can I talk to you about something I want
you to put some adventure into your
story it's not that I didn't like it
last two stories but I want you to
really change it around a little bit he
was in fact I really wanted to the nut
story so I sat down and I you know wrote
it out to the best of my knowledge and
like everything in my life you know when
you write you seek you know when you
write something down two or three
sentences down just by exercising that
pen another idea coming to your mind
something else will come into your mind
and you think that you're gonna get all
those things you know so I write the
story out I cut out the fat and then I
figure out on on some points and then I
do the best I can when I go up there
trust me one of those points I'm gonna
forget one of those sentences I'm gonna
forget it's just natural you just forget
when you're dirty I don't care if you're
dirty 20 or 50 you're gonna forget one
of those lines in a crucial situation
then you'll see it later and him but so
I forget all about this I get up on
stage that night and I gotta be honest
with you when I watch that this is not
happening a few weeks ago I realized a
couple of things from that performance
that were not on the paper at all one
thing was when I talked about the
you know thank the Italians thank God
for Italians thank God for Puerto Ricans
when I called
the Roberto Clemente looking
[ __ ] that was off the top of my
[ __ ] head because I was on a roll you
know so one of the things that happens
rap performance you click on this is not
happening the story of the nun wait till
you get to the part about my rage when
you watch the part about my rage you see
that my eyes swell up with tears of them
because I'm telling the story about pain
something talk and even with all the
writing you do at home something comes
out on stage that if you watch it you'll
see my eyes well up because I meant it
from the bottom of my heart you know I
go one when I attacked that [ __ ] nun
it was I I was looking I was living in
this [ __ ] I'm living at this [ __ ]
Catholic school they're beating on me
I'm [ __ ] going home on the weekends
you know I'm staying up till 3:00 in the
morning with my parents I'm living this
[ __ ] cowboy life you know I Bruce Lee
had died Roberto Clemente they had died
January 1st in 1973 that knocked my
window when Bruce Lee died July 20th the
one who the [ __ ] he died my [ __ ] I
didn't listen to what there was no
internet guys so whoever tells you you
found out that night on the news is full
of [ __ ] it took us like three [ __ ]
days to find out for days
and then there was not you know there
was no internet you gotta go to a second
Pedialyte oncologist or anything over
here try to get over here interesting it
wasn't like it is nada you get the news
breaking news on Twitter there was
nothing like that so when the Green
Hornet was on I used to watch the Green
Hornet I remember one night throwing a
fit because they didn't get me home in
time don't be giving I still remember
this [ __ ] you know I can't tell you what
episodes I didn't look it up I can't say
how many episodes with a shot it wasn't
on for a long time that's it
it's not interrupt but that's a crazy
thing for me is the TV shows I loved as
a kid I thought they were wrong for
years and then like it was awful
one zeizel that was either on for one
season of two seasons I didn't even look
I didn't want to do any research I
wanted to talk from the heart today I
didn't look I didn't do any [ __ ]
research nothing I just wanted to talk
to you people from what I had my
memories so I won booth death on that
Bruce Lee died it hit me hard
and you know I mean here's a kid that I
watch the Green Hornet and then one day
this guy disappears and yet I remember
them el Chino because that's what I'm a
koala Mitchie needle you know a little
in Spanish and chinito means a little
Chinese guy so I would tell my mom I
gotta go home and watch The Green Hornet
my mom spoke Spanish you don't know what
the [ __ ] of green water this is like it
easy and I would say you know the show
Colette you need them and that was a
half hour that my mom had a break I
would sit there and do the same moves he
did and then I got hit in the head with
the [ __ ] lunchbox and my mother gave
me an opportunity to join karate and I
was like this is what that's not good
she need to used to do and I couldn't
think of his name but then my god father
used to take me to movie theaters on
42nd Street but from time to time he
would take me to Chinatown and there was
a movie down there in Chinatown New York
City not a Chinese Theater it was a
white theatre but since it was in
Chinatown it played kung-fu movies so
what if you want me to give you a name
of the first kung-fu movie I saw I don't
know I just enjoyed it because I was at
karate with you know doing [ __ ] cakes
and like the fist on my ghee and I
didn't even if you want me to tell you I
remembered Bruce Lee or whatever I
didn't I just called him at chanita and
I know I was doing that and Here I am in
a martial arts movie theater and I don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on and then
somewhere around 1969 1970 when I was
about seven six or seven the martial art
movie business [ __ ] exploded and I
remember being at Sacred Heart School
for Boys and running home and telling
whoever my godfather my stepfather I
gotta go see Five Fingers at that five
thing as a death was the first movie
that put us over the top about a student
that trains and his master
they're gonna kill him and he develops
the palm of strength I forget what it's
called the palm of debt and that's where
you get these [ __ ] rocks that are
heated and you gotta put your hands on
them trust me uncle Joey did it and you
got to get a bag like a bean bag and put
a bag over it and you got to wipe this
[ __ ] juice on your hands and [ __ ]
pound your hands like this to get him
hard you do this all day nothing
happened to my hands my hands I still
got [ __ ] hands till today they're soft
is [ __ ] but you know you go to the
process I did the whole thing and then
in the fourth grade one night we had
just come out of the shower that had to
be maybe 12 to 16 of us in the dormitory
I was in the fourth grade I was in
sister Alice's or sister Alice was the
[ __ ] gym leader of the fourth-grade
dormitory and we were watching the show
by the name of happy days with the Fonz
and it's you Richie whatever Richie
Cunningham and all right
and the next thing you know in between
one of those commercial breaks they
showed the trailer to mother [ __ ] the
Chinese connection
aka Fist of Fury it got released over
there is Fist of Fury but it got
released here is the Chinese connection
if you get a minute YouTube that [ __ ] we
I forgot to tell you something I want
you to look for The Little Rascals cake
it's very important that you find Little
Rascals cake okay so please so where
were we
they just on a commercial for a
commercial for Enter the Dragon came on
now we're a bunch of [ __ ] fourth
graders I don't know if you guys got
kids or whatever fourth graders we watch
the Fonz
they give us snacks class a [ __ ] milk
me I drink like water or cooling and
whatever the [ __ ] is that a drink no
wall sitting around there watching this
[ __ ] Fonz and all of a sudden you
know like with it's from a bunch of
rowdy fourth graders and well I can
three man packs and we're telling
stories during the TV show but when
Bruce Lee Chinese connection came on and
they showed that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] in that circle seen the
Chinese connection that's the scene you
saw on the trailer guys I gotta be
honest with you the [ __ ] the the I
gotta be honest Ian at the [ __ ] room
came to a halt even the [ __ ] nun it
was like you could just you could drop a
pen in there and that kid did not
[ __ ] move none of us moved we were
frozen our jaws had dropped we had been
overcome [ __ ] shitty Chitty Bang Bang
[ __ ] the Love Bug [ __ ] the world's
greatest athlete [ __ ] Disney movies [ __ ]
Charlie Brown this room was filled with
kids from the five [ __ ] barrows and
Staten Island these were little [ __ ]
animals [ __ ] Mickey Mouse [ __ ] Donald
Duck [ __ ] Snoopy we had just [ __ ] got
our world rock this Chinese guy just
kicked the [ __ ] out of 50 people on
[ __ ] TV at 8 o'clock on national TV
on a Tuesday [ __ ] night for two days I
could not wait when my stepfather pulled
up to get me that Friday fun that
Thursday night
I remember saying he was like what do
you want to do this we're gonna go
I just need one favor from you we need
to find out where the Chinese connection
is playing and we went and we went to
Clifton New Jersey to the route three
driving if anybody's parents ever talked
about that [ __ ] place hit me back I
went to see a bunch of movies there five
thing is a debt [ __ ] but Chinese
connection comes out of my [ __ ] veins
there when I left that [ __ ] driving
thena I was hooked okay I was learning
karate but I had to get to the bottom of
this kung fu [ __ ] somewhere along the
line this [ __ ] was just too much he was
doing for I don't even know I found that
I don't know if you had to buy black
belt magazine in those days to find out
everything about Bruce Lee and when
Bruce Lee came over that's all you found
him black belt magazine with Bruce Lee
your articles Brewster your articles
Bruce Lee articles who he was training
by the lovable Bob and you
what I was right there with him now for
me I watch all these people say what he
meant to them and what he didn't mean to
them
to me man he [ __ ] meant I don't know
at the time I couldn't [ __ ] tell you
all I know is that me and every one of
my friends was Bruce Lee crazy
what's Bruce Lee crazy we used to go to
Chinatown we used to buy the outfits you
know there's these envelopes that used
to come out in Chinatown every Friday
and it was ten five five assorted
pictures of Bruce Lee from all his
different movies and there was like only
ten pictures but they would give you
nine of them and one of them they made
it really hard to get it was like one
with him with a new chunks or something
so you had to keep buying the envelope
oh it was like trading cards ain't
buying them until you get that one and
then once you collected them I wonder
what that collection is worth now I
wonder what those envelopes will work
now if anybody ever kept those envelopes
from [ __ ] Chinatown here you know if
you got all the grandparents I grew up
he used to go to Chinatown in 73 find
that they got those envelopes any of
those they used to be like blackened
like whoever did him was a thot leave
that Island woman did that was a [ __ ]
scam because they were just printing him
and putting them in there but I'm gonna
say on the serious side Bruce like it
just took off guys it took off like
medical marijuana it took off like crack
it took off like the internet took off
like cell phones Bruce Lee took off like
nothing you ever saw before and America
kept sitting back waiting for his
[ __ ] movies he released where the
dragon now I don't know if where the
dragon came out before after Enter the
Dragon I I don't remember the whole
[ __ ] thing but I do remember and to
the dragon coming out and me knowing he
was dead
and me sitting there crying like a [ __ ]
at the Union City cinema and you didn't
say New Jersey and so it was
the big box mr. fury the way of the
Dragon and then Game of Death
where's last four and then he was
shooting game of debt and they [ __ ]
redid it with some [ __ ] little
Chinese guy making noises and by that
time it was all about Chinese people
[ __ ] manipulated us for years with
older Bruce Lee footage everybody was
threatening that they had other Bruce
Lee footage so every movie that came out
they would say Bruce Lee Bruce Lee Bruce
Lee and it was a lie
it was like a picture of Bruce Lee in it
well like a [ __ ] Chinese people were
ruthless they were getting like there's
another guy's body and putting Ruth
Lee's face on it they were ruthless and
then Sonny Chiba came and that took away
the Bruce Lee thing for a while and but
in people's hearts like mine that
startled Bruce Lee's death stung and
when you watch this is not happening
you you see it in my face that it's
coming up again after [ __ ] 30 [ __ ]
years that poor bastards been dead for
47 [ __ ] years until this day when I
tap into it it's still [ __ ] and I
don't happen to it a lot I tapped into
it that night obviously when I was on
[ __ ] stage it came back to [ __ ]
haunt me those [ __ ] skeletons because
I was ready to cry up on that [ __ ]
stage I had to control myself because my
father's death hurt as much or Bruce
Lee's death hurt as much as my father's
death and it hurt as much as Roberto
Clemente's death and there was a bunch
of people dying in those days Morrison
died [ __ ] Hendrix had died so America
was just getting used to no john john f
kennedy had died people were just
[ __ ] dying from the time I could [ __ ]
him I mean John F Kennedy died in 66 but
we were just on a [ __ ] trend you know
every year somebody was dying [ __ ]
the brother died didn't want to Luther
King died I mean it was just like we
were used to [ __ ] people dying but
now as people on our feet like it was
people you didn't give a [ __ ] but now as
people you didn't give a [ __ ] but I can
tell you man that I probably need it I
probably today looking back at it I
probably need therapy therapy from Bruce
Lee's death
while then when my mother died that
brought back all those [ __ ] feelings
and I don't know why Bruce Lee's death
affected me so much so now I'm going to
look at the other part of my life I met
a quote you know I always loved the
Beatles I love the Beatles because they
[ __ ] us here a little bit daddy that
is say let the Beatles [ __ ] with them
and well that's what you saw they just
did sometimes life imitates art okay you
any of those guys I said I said on that
tape Oh on the friendship tape I talked
about how all you need is three friends
and you could take over the world
couple weeks ago I wanted to put some
friends on which I'm gonna I'm gonna go
back again but I'm gonna put it in
chunks of threes I put him in a chunk of
threes to let you know the first batch
of three friends I had that let me know
I could take over the world Steven Villa
Georgie and Colangelo
okay everything I've said on those
[ __ ] things I've lived up to now you
ready for this one I get in the [ __ ]
trouble I moved to Boulder within six
weeks I'm back in trouble and I gotta
get on a plane
the psychology psychologically where do
I go I go to San Francisco and as soon
as I hit the San Francisco when I wasn't
stealing or doing drugs or spending time
when my girlfriend was trying to find
that where Bruce Lee used to hang up
that's what I was born and nobody had a
[ __ ] answer for me like he knows I am
like wet what hospital was he born at
you know where was he
whatever I mean it was [ __ ] weird how
I went to San Francisco and between us I
could lay and you know between us is
what we do here I could tell you the
truth that I thought
I went to San Francisco in the back in a
search of Bruce Lee like I didn't know I
want to learn more by them I went up -
for the Chinese community oh my god they
said some good Chinese food up there and
s it was quite forget with the name of
the restaurant North Star Chinese
restaurant or something I'm badass in
San Francisco was the best Szechuan beef
I ever had every time I was in there I
felt like Bruce Lee
this were Bruce Lee and my stupid
cocaine mine but okay let's get back to
I get into comedy and basically guys
when I [ __ ] in 1994-95 I was lost but
I was found because yes my life was lost
when I was focused on comedy like I was
really really really really into comedy
so I was really lost but I was really
found and I had enough when I had to
leave balda I didn't know I was leaving
Boulder I just knew that what was going
on in Boulder wasn't working and all the
hobbyist sites or popping up that I
eventually would have had to leave when
I didn't know but eventually something
wasn't gonna be right sure enough I get
thrown out of the comedy works and I'm
having problems at home with my ex-wife
and litang and I go you know what I
[ __ ] go to Michigan by this time it's
May I know I got a I gotta figure
something out of my life I can't I'm
driving to Baltimore from Denver two
times a month in a [ __ ] car I'm
driving to Michigan from Boulder in a
[ __ ] car and this is what my life was
I knew I had to find the base of
operations could I move to Michigan I
know a couple guys in Michigan can I
move to Baltimore I'm from Jersey it's
just a drive down to Baltimore but I
wasn't ready to be home so what I did
was I go to Michigan to do a weekend and
I meet a girl
now I'm looking for change in my life
I'm looking for home new base of comedy
this girl's plan was to pack up when we
left each other on Sunday her plan was
to back up in a few days
spend a few days with a mother then show
up in Boulder and she was gonna move to
Seattle
she was only come see me before she
moved to Seattle so I like the girl
Boulder wasn't working and all of a
sudden I thought about Seattle I'm like
[ __ ] that's what Bruce Lee started this
whole [ __ ] journey you know I had
been lost and when you're lost I always
say just go home go home and you'll find
the answer go back to your mother's bed
sleep downstairs in the basement go walk
to your grammar school walk the apart
that you play that they'll all come back
to you after a few days what you were
meant to be who you are and why you're
doing what you're doing I'll come back
to you because when you'll walk those
[ __ ] steps that you did as a kid or
I'll come back to you I said you know
what this shit's gonna Seattle I got
nothing going on here
there was a comedy newspaper I want on
then they had all these [ __ ] comedy
clubs that were in Seattle at the time
Washington [ __ ] ad you know all these
volcano room [ __ ] underground giggles
you know here I'm working in Denver with
two club you know and I said you know
what in my heart I want to go up there
and do comedy and to be with this girl
but in my soul I really want to go up
there to walk the streets Bruce Lee did
so from the time I got there I had a
window I when I was going to leave that
year but I think the second day I went
right up to Capitol Hill wherever it's
called I didn't look it up again I'm
just telling you from memory just
because I wanted to dig deep in this
podcast the second day I told the girl I
was with a girl we got to do something
she's like I got that a Friday night
Saturday we went to the club downtown
and went to a show there that night
and then that Sunday she goes you know
we just know you get to a town you want
to go sightseeing she's like well we go
to the [ __ ] Farmers Market on us I go
listen let's put a halt to that I go
let's go see Bruce Lee's Brett and she's
like what are you [ __ ] talking about
I don't want to go to Bruce Lee's grave
I [ __ ] him oh my god dude ask people
on the street so I like ask somebody I
said when you go to Bruce Lee's grave
but he's got that thing capital you know
those days there was no [ __ ] Bruce
Lee's grave four point three miles make
a left you know there was none of that
[ __ ] so you didn't know you know I'm
saying it wasn't like that there was
probably like a map at that time you
know the star map like a star map I
don't know guys I don't know so they
said that what's up in Capitol Hill or
something like that some hell we drove
up there and I swear to God
we drew up we drew we draw we drove on
to a pod the garage gas station and I
didn't get out at all before I could say
another guy where's Bruce Lee's Cemetery
he told me you know before you asked go
up to the corner make a right make a
left he goes don't try to close park
close park close to the cemetery you
won't get in it's uh it's you won't get
in right it's private it's private so
one thing led to another we parked we
walk like a half a mile now there was a
problem because four people don't know
this I don't know anybody from the
Washington area listen to the podcast
please correct me on this let me know
what the truth is here I don't know if
they buried Jimi Hendrix and Bruce Lee
in the same cemetery there's a story to
that why they could because then you
have Kurt Cobain so you had a separate
them right rather separate somebody had
broken into and just whose grave I stole
his fingers I don't [ __ ] know I don't
know if how real it is these are just
rumors year when you're in Seattle right
so they had a separate
because they got too much attention too
many people visit you know Jimi Hendrix
and too many people visit Cobain Kurt
Cobain but this is before called band
though Cobain was dead already when I
was up there this is 96 nine this is 95
so Cobain was already dead he had just
died he was fresh in the hole the magnet
even haven't gotten on him yet so I get
up there and guys I'm not supposed to
walk into [ __ ] cemeteries I avoid
cemeteries like the [ __ ] like I just
avoid them I avoid cemeteries period I
don't like them I feel uncomfortable of
them when I go to my mother's cemetery I
do it just to see her out of respect I
cleaned up when I gotta clean up and I
get the [ __ ] out of there I've never
like cemeteries except when I was a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] crazy man after my
mother died I cut through that cemetery
not Bergen I took a couple shits in
there but at that time I didn't care
link give a [ __ ] about anything but in
this sort of a real day I [ __ ] hate
cemeteries okay and I hate them more in
the daytime that I do at night it's not
a spooky thing I just don't like [ __ ]
cemeteries and against my own [ __ ]
beliefs I walked into that cemetery and
man if you've never gone to Bruce Lee's
grave you have to go and I'm gonna tell
you why because you're gonna understand
that was the completion of the circle
for me of my life after that I was
rested like you know I was good after
that like I had put that ghost to sleep
in my life I don't know why I went to
the cemetery I was crazy about it and I
walked in there and as you walk up you
know you're hitting something special
you start seeing flowers on the floor
and pieces of paper written in notes and
then you walk up and it's just a
beautiful thing he's bare he was buried
there with his son already him and
Brandon had been buried there
Bruce's pictures on the thing and for
maybe I don't know without exaggeration
ten feet in circumference of the circle
that cemetery of his plot is all Bruce
Lee related it's people come from all
over the world and bring notes and
they're open so you're supposed to read
them wow it's amazing how many years is
the bill 50 years no no 60 years ed for
47 years he died in 73 those movies came
out when I was a child and they stuck
with me so much and it's like he said
he's stepping up for the underdog
I love the underdog I've been an
underdog since day one how could I not
love the underdog I bet that underdog
Saturday night you know I love and I
love an underdog story I love somebody
who you know and I listen guys and all
that [ __ ] was going on you want me to
sit here and talk I knew that they
[ __ ] him why the kungfu i know that i
boycotted kung fu personally at that
time at the age of [ __ ] 9 i boycotted
kung fu' like I wasn't gonna watch this
but I heard in rumors that that was
Bruce Lee's show we were all excited
about [ __ ] tongue foo and they gave
me the David Carradine and people like
Ming up his dog we boycotted color food
boycott that [ __ ] [ __ ] we are by that
time I was studying karate but I would
work out and you did a city on top of
the bottom of the barrel this place
called foo job PI kung foo it's still
[ __ ] there and I was going there one
of them one of my friends that was a
landlord at my friend's building studied
and we would all practice together and I
would go to foo John Pike hung food was
next to a Carvel so trust me I didn't go
there cuz I wanted to I went there
because I knew if there flew in the air
for now I was having a milkshake
downstairs afterwards and I'm saying I
didn't go there cuz I wanted to yeah at
first it was yeah Bruce Lee in circles
yeah but after that it was about the
chocolate shake afterwards I'm saying
you gotta earn you keep [ __ ] even
then I was I was earning my keep but
it's just so weird how I ended up moving
to Seattle and guys it didn't stop like
after the cemetery I thought I've
investigated I tried to find that was
first school was so I found that
somebody told me where it was so I
actually went to where his first fool
was I I forget what it is today
and I stood in front of it and I tried
breed the same man he breathed I wanted
the same light I want I didn't know what
I was even doing now I was doing this
psychologically but unsightly I was
doing this I just wanted to breathe the
same man he had breathed I want to walk
on the same streets he walked I want and
I don't need to feel that like you know
yeah I got a dream the plan [ __ ] that
one Peter in New York he knows no
moneymaker and now it's never gonna
happen because of Lenny Bruce but that
time wants to see a wrinkled up Joe Diaz
nobody wants it come see me now he's I'm
saying oh I'm losing friends by the day
now I guess though every time I got a
rink why lose a friend that's the shape
of it so you know I [ __ ] walked it I
did everything he could I am guys it's
been 25 years so I forget what are the
goofy should I did out of respect for
Bruce Lee so now Sunday night came and
like I told you guys Monday I didn't
even have the strength to watch that
Sunday night I watched [ __ ] Steve
McQueen and the getaway but I gotta tell
you something monday was a [ __ ]
boring day and I went my own I won
against my own rule and I [ __ ] him
watched be water and I watched it I
don't know if it was because what was
going on around me and that it was like
it didn't tell me what I really wanted
to hear they told me about this [ __ ] I
already knew well I wanted to hear about
how his father used to dress up like a
girl when he was a kid because he felt
the Spirit was looking for him if he
could confuse the spirit he could save
Bruce Lee you know I wanted to hear all
about that [ __ ] his dad's a little
[ __ ] but didn't have any of that but
it didn't really matter Tuesday uh
Monday night I think one of the church
guys man hold my hair out of Milwaukee
great guy he sent me a message and he
goes what do you think of it like how
you know it was okay but then I did what
I go you know what was like
spreadin what the [ __ ] I think I should
let me [ __ ] watch it again and last
night I watched it again and last night
at the end I cried and I understood why
I love them it was because of the
underdog thing he was a [ __ ] light he
was a tiny guy listen if you think I
bought into the fight even at the age of
once I seen one shoot a [ __ ] guy once
I saw my stepdad shoot a guy in the leg
I figured out that movies were fake okay
you ever come to a [ __ ] point where
you you like the daylight you just go I
hate watching wrestling no more like do
you ever have that day that day happens
one day when you're 11 you know every
you get let me the first time you
stopped believing in Santa Claus you
know it's the same thing when you found
out that he wasn't real it was the same
[ __ ] way you know I don't him please
don't get me started on the rest like I
love wrestlers no disrespect one day
just watching it and you like this is
fake this [ __ ] ain't watching some walk
I want to see him get hit with a
headbutt I want to see his head blow up
you know and I don't want to [ __ ]
just see a little blood the face [ __ ]
you know so that's how your life is you
watch something until you see behind the
curtain then you move the [ __ ] on in I'm
saying so it's just weird out I watched
it again and I caught things I didn't
catch the first time you know I caught
and I wasn't after him Bruce Lee died if
you know anything about me guys I was a
little Bible beating [ __ ] when him
Bruce Lee died so I didn't like the fact
that he had been this is up guys this is
how much of a prude your uncle Joey was
I didn't like the fact that they found
them at a woman's house that wasn't his
wife yeah I didn't like it even if
they're even in the [ __ ] fifth grade
it always didn't seem right to me his
death never made sense to me was the
conspiracy guys who were we we got no
time we got real problems to deal with
in the world use and this baseball
coming back can a [ __ ] suck my dick
again in Vegas you know you know you
know you got a you got a lot of things
on your mind number two questions what's
that the minute one well because people
can't do [ __ ] no more because they call
with things a change
thanks for different genes so
everybody's fair yes it's for difference
I guess I get dick throw went on them
don't let you got a six-foot dick you're
no [ __ ] what do you do for the dick
extension on again today I'll be six
feet away so that's why I don't see how
our strip clubs operated but I'm not
here to talk about Kovac you guys
already took three months of Colvin you
want to talk about Kolby like you want
to talk about hemorrhoids I get it what
I'm trying to say is that I watched it
again and you know it just it's just one
of those things of my childhood that was
then it was when my mother was alive it
was that life you know I tried to call
my friend being the pre Thea there saw
his name on Facebook you know if he
wasn't a shy little [ __ ] as he was I put
him on zoom but he's already told me
I'll never do your podcast so don't ask
I won't call in you know he was there at
my house before when my mother I honor
his friendship because I knew all those
guys BC before Coco's mother died so
Bruce Lee to me was something that was a
part of my life when my mother was alive
and will always be it's a part of that
life it was the first chapter you don't
like I'm doing this [ __ ] book right
now and I'm trying to figure out how to
break it out you know because I've had
like six [ __ ] lives
I had the [ __ ] Catholic boy life
where I'm telling you that I was pissed
off I still never going to see the
Godfather and coming my eyes well I
cover my eyes with the warm wide-open
wouldn't attendees came out during the
Godfather
Apollonia you know I was that much of a
[ __ ] Catholic little nerd and then
there's that [ __ ] evil period you
know the other day people are [ __ ]
banging out Marky Wahlberg because of
hate crimes or whatever the [ __ ] he
didn't and Boston well guess what guys
you know what man when you have hate in
your heart that's the kind of stupid
[ __ ] you do you know else did that uncle
Joey I would sit there at night in the
[ __ ] Hudson County Park and these
broken men would
and I lied home and tell him I was gonna
suck that dick and then me and three
guys who jump him and beat him up that's
not [ __ ] normal but that was who I
was dead if you want to judge me by that
now 30 years later be my [ __ ] guest
it's that time who I am today how do I
know because today I [ __ ] sit there
at 4 o'clock and we got coloring for an
hour me and my daughter and I got a
subtract numbers to figure out the
pencil so number 2 is red number 3 is
pink
number 4 is green and all through here I
got three plus one nine plus eight and I
gotta figure out all the math and after
I do that for now I gotta sit with a kid
and read three books she reads him to me
so I know I'm not the same person so I
don't give a [ __ ] about that you know
that type of [ __ ] and then you have the
life the cocaine life that [ __ ]
cocaine-fueled wife that son almost
killed me but it turned me into a comedy
[ __ ] savage because even though I had
that cocaine in my system I still had
coke coke calmly was the light at the
end of the tunnel tommy was the light at
the end of the tunnel for me I knew once
I reached my comedy thing I would shed
that cocaine skin and thank God 13 years
ago I [ __ ] did so there was always
something and now I have a then from 90
[ __ ] from 2007 to 2010 I was a
different [ __ ] I don't know who
the [ __ ] I was I was just finding out
who the [ __ ] I was and then from 2010
and now I meant we I had a kid
you know I moved on to theaters as a
comic I mean you know I've had so much
the [ __ ] go on cuz I don't even know
what the [ __ ] I am anymore but that's
how fast your life's I've had [ __ ]
five lives so if you want to judge me on
something but anyway going back to Bruce
Lee to me at the end of it when I watch
that ESPN thing at the end it was just
who I was at one time so I cherished
that hey I think he was a tough guy he
beat up mom are we guys it was the
[ __ ] movies but
I also remember people's behavior after
Bruce Lee came especially my own you
know it gave me the will to stand up for
myself you know his first movie is the
Big Boss release here is Fist of Fury
and if you know anything about that
movie the first hour that movie is
horrible
you know why because Bruce Lee don't
fight it was like Buffy the Vampire
Slayer Buffy the Vampire Slayer yeah you
had to wait the whole show for Buffy to
start throwing [ __ ] science and you
can't really see that [ __ ] remember
that when you'd really want you coming
with the boots and that tight little ass
yeah but you had to wait do we have to
put up with 22 minutes of bad acting the
[ __ ] twins the other ugly redhead
girl for me to see Buffy bitch-slap
somebody that came from the old school
Batman formula where you had to put up
with 20 minutes of Batman - Batman gave
somebody a beat no [ __ ] slapped him him
and Robin and I came from the same old
school as Green Hornet you had a [ __ ]
wait 20 minutes to watch Green Hornet
throw 20 kicks that's how they would
hold you right because you're ready for
something this Chinese got a smart touch
smack on white people or a black dude no
disrespect African American and next
thing you know that you would have to
wait twenty two minutes that's the same
thing they did to you in the big boss
aka Fist of Fury but you know why
because he hadn't made a promise that he
wasn't gonna fight and he didn't throw a
punch so there was a riot and somebody
ripped his chain and broke the promise
Wow so you know that right there was
showing you as a young adult what as a
character what character was that's the
first time I learned about character
that before that scene he was gonna
throw a punch and they held him back and
they reminded him you made a promise to
your mother or your uncle you gotta
watch the movie and spent a long time
ago
so that was little pieces of character
he showed you you know in that scene
when when he faced the boss what
happened when in the big boss when they
[ __ ] when they [ __ ] took him out
to dinner and they made him the boss how
he treated the employees then he
realized he had made a mistake and he
became Bruce Lee and
was and he went down to the [ __ ]
guy's house [ __ ] killed a bunch of
[ __ ] that's the scene where
he's eating the potato chips and he
kicks the guys in the ball to explode
and they both go down and then he jumps
the fence and he kills the [ __ ] Sun
and the [ __ ] father but so yeah it
was about killing or whatever but it was
about a promise that in fact that he
comes back in another movie called Fist
of Fury got released in China but in the
United States a guy released the Chinese
[ __ ] connection and he releases a
Chinese connection and that movie it's
about him coming home and his teacher
dying but his teacher was in great shape
how to [ __ ] die who would do this so
why everybody else's tunnel emeriti was
sucking win like we do today walking
around with your finger up your ass
looking at your [ __ ] iPhone to see
what idiot texture you're not seeing
what's in funny and he's like dog
something is not right here and one
night he found two Japanese guys that I
applied to kill the [ __ ] teacher and
he goes off and then at the end he has
to turn himself in so that the Japanese
people don't destroy the school and as
he goes outside they're about to shoot
him and instead of running in he runs at
them leaving their everybody in that
movie theater was crying crying dog when
we left when we left up cuz after we
played at that there you know you had to
go see it first with a parent and after
that you went you had to go see the
movie first dog [ __ ] in your
neighborhood and tell your friends body
with the seats Bruce Lee in the movies
bad go home I should follow 50 cents see
if we catch the four o'clock matinee
over and a small Baba that playing 148th
Street and I member taking my friends to
go see that movie I saw Chinese
connections in the movie theater without
exaggeration I probably paid 25 times to
see the child option the movie theater
there was a movie theater that used to
let me go there my he used to drink at
my mother's bar it was called Sina Tony
I'm like 14 strippers of Cuban movie
theater the owner had a wig time yeah
he would come into the bar and do a
couple bumps so there was like a rule
like he'd come in and drink but I could
go into his movie theater whenever I
wanted right
what a gorilla's and just going and
background watch movies I can't tell you
how many times I saw that movie there at
night like I would have nothing to do
but I would go mom I'm bored and she'd
go take the cab go down and see that
Tony and watch the 11 o'clock movie come
back at 2:00 we'll close at 3:00 damn
take care by yourself oh yeah you know
we you didn't city was a small town Wow
Studio City and I don't get lost no bees
might kidnap you it wasn't like that
there was a lot more trust on the street
right III didn't have the history that
you had with with Bruce Lee but I
thought though I thought it was great
last night like because it's you're
talking about his being a good person
and standing up for people and he did he
he had that come through in his movies
but he had to come from at least in the
documentary they were talking about he
had he purposely had that stuff come
through in the movies because that's who
he was as a person and like stuff that
stood out to me was how many times he
like came back like I don't think I was
just relating it to myself I was like I
don't know if I would keep going after
so many people telling you know like
time after time this is what life is
about looks and Clint Eastwood did
spaghetti westerns Bruce Lee came here
you know one of the things that I like
that they highlighted was the time he
had grown up and what he'd learned from
what we learn from you know the story is
that they were very mad at him for
teaching non Chinese the art of kung fu
and then there's a plot I mean there's
so many different myths and stories and
lies and there's so much great
information out there what we're talking
about never giving up never giving up
you know when you come to this town look
I know okay I give you an example I know
a certain Mexican comic we used to
always come up to me and go I will never
take a role where they degrade a Mexican
well that dude run his son Picton
okay he's ready to shoot himself today
because of cuz he had 20 of those roles
he's gonna had 20 of those roles where
whatever it's up to whatever you want to
do I mean you never want to portray
yourself as a Jewish man in Auschwitz
you know because your family and stuff
like that there's certain things you
won't want to put a to portray yourself
as but also at the end of the day it's
just a job right to get yourself
acquainted with what's going on what the
biggest thing they did to him was steel
kung-fu from them yeah that was clearly
that was heartbreaking because we all
fought it as little kids that was his
and every kid I hung out with banked
boycotted it my [ __ ] fault
[ __ ] that [ __ ] like you weren't allowed
in my neighborhood they even talk about
[ __ ] dog food
who is the guy who played Genghis Khan
my white guy or John what it was it was
horrible you know and you talk about all
these bad people and [ __ ] like this and
all these pain like I said in the
beginning listen there's a lot of
[ __ ] fakers out there people who
stand there you know behind closed doors
as well [ __ ] matters look up Marlon
Brando did the 73 when he sent the
[ __ ] Indian woman to receive his
Academy Award because they should
portray Indians as Indians this has
always been a problem in Hollywood right
then you know this has always been a
problem in Hollywood and and you know
yesterday Michael B Jackson on Monday
was talking about you know hiring more
black people and on Hollywood you know
know how they coming up with that in
eighteen years of not the contender the
chick that's needs a boyfriend on ABC
the 18 season in 40 episodes they only
had one black girl Oh a bachelor you
know we look at all these things now you
see these this stuff from the Bruce Lee
documentary you know about racism in 69
and 68 and 70 and you're looking at the
things that are going on with today and
you're like yeah what has changed what
is [ __ ] changed you know we're still
trying to change people's mind but again
until you change your mind behind closed
doors
and have a pure heart nothing nothing
Goods gonna happen when you say if he
when you look at your [ __ ] friends
and go is he really my friend or is he a
token friend we live in Hollywood guys
will you have token [ __ ] friends then
token friends you know what that means
they contact you when it it's good for
them ok 10 things could happen
earthquakes can happen they don't call
you but one day out of the blue they
were just thinking about you and you
know why I got you on the phone I got
this project coming up and you're like
really yeah you know we're all token
[ __ ] friends guess what I'm not a
token to [ __ ] nobody you know you
know you see two comedians hanging out
or whatever I could tell you 20,000
situations why they're hanging out it's
you they're hanging out cuz they live
and die for each other or they hanging
out cuz one wants one from the other one
when you hear me unrolling I could be on
the road and every [ __ ] day guys I
just call Joe right now I want to be on
next Monday and he would say absolutely
I don't do that I don't abuse our
friendship and I want the show to be
very organic I want me to come on there
twice a year you know during the
holidays and maybe during the fourth of
July and go [ __ ] off I like to do the
first guest of the year we're to start
the year off on the right foot but I
don't abused their friendship I don't
want none from Joe I want to spread [ __ ]
here in Hollywood that that's not the
[ __ ] case right so we live in a
[ __ ] polluted place so when Loosli
was he was so hurt
he was probably hurt the way I was after
a long a shot you know while we shooting
along the shore I didn't call anybody on
that moving they'd pick up the phone the
day the [ __ ] movie ended like what to
call the next day by the check or
something and I had to leave messes and
nobody called you back these are the
realities of [ __ ] Hollywood you know
when you're on a TV show everybody wants
to be your friend when you got no TV
show you know these are realities a
Hollywood did-did-did Bruce Lee really
like you know Bruce Lee and Steve
McQueen with great thoughts and friends
I've heard 200 stories about where they
dear
they call each other every day or they
Hollywood friends I think you know I
heard that they both wanted what the
other guy had Steve McQueen didn't want
to be a successful Hollywood actor he
wanted just a bit slap people and Bruce
Lee didn't want to bitch-slap people he
wanted to be the world's greatest actor
you know like very popular he wanted to
bring Chinese culture into the limelight
he wanted to promote all these things so
you know in that case yes and I
obviously can't change who someone is in
Bruce was an incredibly hard worker but
the thing that I can't get out of my
mind from that documentary was they were
talking to his wife and they were
talking about I think was right after
The Green Hornet and they were saying
how it was tough times they didn't have
a lot of money but it was probably the
happiest time of her life because all
the kids were together Bruce was there
and they had time for each other and I
like what's going on right now exactly
and I'm like she should you not try that
like nothing you shouldn't try that hard
but should you have different goals try
that hard for what like looking back who
knows what killed Bruce but should Bruce
have been like you know what I'm gonna
be the number one stuntman I'll have
some movies and I'll get to play with my
kids at night like like I'm just rather
than focus so intently on on being the
star like just that line she was about
what so once he got you know once he got
that's at that point and that's the
truth look at us now look what we're
learning now look at what this [ __ ]
coronavirus has taught us that for some
people who were single it's taught you
how to live without nobody coming over
you know and you're by yourself and I
you know I got you guys back I always
call you Steve whoever eye contact or
you guys Dean Del Ray I talked to Theo
dia de you know because I know what it
is I know how I go crazy at night you
think I like watching TV from [ __ ]
5-2 mile
I've never done that this is the first
time for me for all this [ __ ] I've never
[ __ ] done this so this is very hard
for me right now
I just go along with it at first I need
the edibles to do it you know I went
overboard and now I've accepted my faith
I know exactly what I'm doing and I know
exactly how I want to do it once proofs
went to China and you heard him at the
end of the first movie he didn't know
what direction it was gonna go right and
not now so now what happens so now what
what else did you learn from at the end
of it at the end of it you learned about
a word called hypocrisy and I want all
young actors and comics if this is what
you feel didn't or anything you'd do to
learn about what happened at the end at
the end he had to go somewhere else and
make him 91 million dollars five hundred
and twenty-one million dollars by
today's standards and what happened
automatically America sent Warner
Brothers over there with a cheque to
partner up with him Raymond chow was
unknown to the American [ __ ] public
Raymond chow cut such a good deal then
look who the family movies Raymond chow
and on to produce that were American
really oh yeah they gave him everything
they had to give him everything after
that because he gave up a great you know
you know to his death at some levels
could have been because he switched
governments he wasn't gonna make money
for some certain Chinese people anymore
I mean there's a bunch of mystery
surrounding this in my world right now
47 years later it was god that's it one
day you wake up and you're done Jim
Morrison went my friend Anthony Boz Ana
went my friend Dan regel what but I'm
still here at 57 but how could you but
can you imagine too high a week before
your dream comes true a week I don't
know I'm scared to death I think I'm
gonna die March [ __ ] first because
the praana movie comes up much I feel as
soon as I saw them like
by March 2nd I'm saying because it's a
problem movies coming out not you know
nothing I'm Bruce Lee I'm just saying
you know it's it's it's it's hard it's a
story that it's a story about love it's
a story about balls listen my favorite
song is Sinatra he did it his way
when you come out to this California
there's a system and then it becomes
your system that is your art that is
what you have to offer right now I do it
art you know people get it wrong
my dear friend Joe Rogan says I'm the
funniest a you listen I'm the funniest
guy when you open up a window and let me
go and attack through it as far as a
stand-up a stand-up requires certain
levels of stand-up the best stand-up in
the game right now is bill burr after
his last bastion because of the levels
till this day I love the levels a lot of
comics aren't doing that that's the way
I was learned to do comedy my levels
Bill Hicks worked in levels everybody
like that worked on levels even prior in
a way worked on levels not really now
Colin worked in levels that's a
brilliant way of doing comedy I'm a
funny guy when you give me an opening
and I could go through that [ __ ]
window I'm a funny guy when you pull it
out of me and I could go through that
[ __ ] window I don't even know how we
got to this story but Bruce Lee just
taught me that when I got here listen
I'm never really worried about racist
racism I don't know why like it's never
really affecting me have I felt that my
wife asked me last night
have I ever felt it and I gotta be
honest to you yes yes
I always why the people and say no why I
first moved to North Bergen I felt it a
little bit and then throughout the years
it got a lot easier but at the end I
knew I had to get out of North Bergen
because no matter what I have would be
achieve at the end of that always be a
specter and now that doesn't matter to
me I am [ __ ] spec I don't give a [ __ ]
what you know what you take them maybe
I'm Spanish what do I'm gonna do
if you're black they have the
african-american if you're Chinese
whatever somebody but what are we going
with this I'm not sure if you ever
experienced race yeah I'm you're
experienced racism you know Bruce Lee
experienced that he felt that he was
very hurt by it he got [ __ ] in the ass
they took a show from him he went to
China he made his point and then they
had to go get him and that describes the
word hypocrisy now who else did that
happen to that you know anybody else you
know that happened to you're looking at
him you listening to him I was here
since 1997 and I've been rocking guys
guys I'm looking at you at the I I'm
looking at the microphone at the I I've
been killing them since 2004 seriously
that was 13 years and once I started
following morning and I put the longest
yard together
I was a 50/50 comic but when I [ __ ]
ripped your [ __ ] heart out I'd rip
your heart out you've heard the stories
about the [ __ ] Comedy Store nobody
talked to me guys I would beg agents I
would drop off packages every day I
would argue with agents I would make and
I just couldn't not figure it out I
never blamed it on racism I never blamed
it on my felony I didn't know what to
blame it up I didn't know what to blame
it on and then something happened in
2013 that changed all that
because it wasn't even about the talent
guess what happened in 2013 that changed
all that I sold the ticket so it didn't
matter how funny I was in 2006 even
after a longer shot guys even after
seeing the long as yarn you guys know
I'm in that movie and I'm standing right
there with Tracy Morgan all those
[ __ ] if I'm a good agent I'm
like I'm gonna sign that kid because he
ain't [ __ ] today but if I could work
with him right I'll put him on the right
path I can do something with him nobody
talked to me they still they treated me
like I had more [ __ ] HIV than before
it was like they shall next to shall age
leave me here so nobody wanted to talk
to me it was until 2013
till I sold Sal's I sold out sounds more
than 13 tickets and then I sold that San
Francisco or I got like 380 on a
Thursday night with Felicia and all of a
sudden guys you should have seen all the
people that said bad things about me
over the years that said I wouldn't
amount to nothing that wouldn't return
my calls for years all of a sudden that
chance now you got two things to do with
that you're gonna be cocky or you could
just write it off to business
I think 20% of it with some people I was
cocky the other eighty I wrote off the
business and I still do business with
those people because it was all a part
of business you have to realize unless
your [ __ ] once morning you could be
the funniest guy in the world you could
be the best painter in the [ __ ] world
you could draw the best sketches of Lee
you could draw a sketch of the Titanic
but unless you put a value on that and
you figure out how to put a value on
that
mmm you're done you're done
nobody decide to until you decide you
know what that flag of the United States
of America I drew I want $10,000 for and
if you look at some of these eyes and
you explain to them why you want the 10
G for that flag and talk to him with the
right passion they're gonna buy that
[ __ ] flag because it's what value you
put on yourself at the end of the
[ __ ] day so it was really weird when
2013 came so nobody talked to me for
years Rogen's been telling people people
in the club all has been telling I've
been telling people dog watch this
nobody paying attention to me sending
people tapes you know how much money I
spend this and then people tapes how
many tapes I dropped off you know
and then the comic the agents made fools
of me they would go well you have to
sell the whole department how many guys
you got 13 all right let me go down and
sell 13 [ __ ] so I'm gonna drop
all 13 tapes long we voted against you
how many of those I got nice for years
people voted against me but I sold one
ticket and now everybody is my friend
the follows ring is doing so if you
learned anything about that Bruce Lee
thing all at the end was it was a
beautiful story but at the end they have
ago suck his dick and come back and
[ __ ] light his cigarettes and tell
him how much they love Chinese people
and [ __ ] it massages and boo kung
fool and jump up and down and that's at
the end he won he proved his point he
won
you know I admired so many things about
Bruce Lee if he noticed something else
about me I got a white wife got a white
wife that was by [ __ ] I knew I was
going with a plain white chick when I
got into this game
oh I didn't want no [ __ ] a statue is
fake tatted woman I wanted a woman who
was gonna calm me down I run I once
wrote I read a thing about Bruce Lee
that Linda kadra to God the lad waited
until the dragon he was very agitated
and the Dirar Stila wet whatever his
name was a director or the producer said
that Linda to calm him down my wife is
the only person who talked to me like my
wife could talk to me you know the other
night I was watching that person
Sopranos when he's going off in the
house and they having a barbecue and he
finds Janice is real Janice took the
real estate sign off the property and
put it in the back and he comes in and
just starts tormenting Carmela and he
starts yelling like Carmela like did you
god no she came back for a [ __ ] house
and for a falling out of car that
[ __ ] [ __ ] and she's like look at
yourself Tony you have to get back to
therapy and he's like [ __ ] that I don't
even want to [ __ ] talk about that
house I don't laughs sighs she goes over
to the door opens it up this is a mob
boss who's killed people who tells
people to shut the [ __ ] up she slams the
door she goes get out go out there and
enjoy yourself get out there with your
friends and she gets behind them and she
pushes it up to [ __ ] up
and she slams the door
because Jesus Christ and Tony walks out
pissed off and he sees [ __ ] stand there
with a B&E what the [ __ ] are you
laughing about then they twist it around
you know many times my wife twist me
around I'm guessing at least I can quit
doing blow because I didn't want my wife
to find me on the floor I didn't want
that poor soul of a woman to find me on
the floor but it's in the coincidence my
thing I want what a white wife would
Bruce Lee got a white wife I'm not
stupid
he got to those Heights because he had a
woman who calmed him down he didn't have
a wife that was [ __ ] a piece up you
know you want to marry on peace God 10
years from now she doesn't want to [ __ ]
her trainer all right you want that arm
pee whatever I married a woman who
suited my [ __ ] needs somebody who I
felt you know what man my wife doesn't
run the house but she keeps me in check
and that's what Linda did for Bruce
Bruce is a [ __ ] wild man what what
did I say when he had this door that she
had him wrapped around her finger yeah
what the [ __ ] wait think I'm doing that
this afternoon
you think I want to go to the beach and
get I'm 17% again this bit by a shark
I'm CUBAN 18 if he keno [ __ ] talk
about the fungi toenail not attract
sharks like a [ __ ]
they love fun guys it's like I'm Tanya I
go to the beach I dream about coming
home with one leg every time I love this
Beach well I'm coming home with one leg
well I'll leave the house they love the
beach that I get in the car I'm like I'm
pushing this brake cuz I ain't gonna be
pushed break I'm gonna come home they
gonna call me Joey one leg
Joey stumps Joey [ __ ] something guys
thank you very much for listening to our
little Bruce Lee thing today I'm sorry
the [ __ ] County didn't match up the
Monday's but that's what's great about
the church they're all different
sometimes the silly sometimes we got
serious to talk about a joke still come
on from time to time and sometimes these
podcasts of my love we change every
[ __ ] week okay so strap a pair on and
that's it and that's the
it was a beautiful Wednesday if you
haven't watched the documentary yet I'm
[ __ ] sorry I'm sorry if I we just
gave you the topical stuff you could
still watch it don't hit me up later and
say looking Joey you [ __ ] spoiler
alert spoiler alert was when they don't
tell you they're coming he's I'm saying
that's who a spoiler there is when they
don't tell you that coming when they
don't tap you on the shoulder you know
get ready for that [ __ ] jizz no coming
to hit you with I had the cupboard six
months ago you know I'm saying it's
that's spoiler alert telling you about
some movie that's [ __ ] nothing right
spoiler alerts right before you come
your mother knocks on the door don't
forget you gotta go to church that
spoiler you're banging the chicken off
on your grandmother pills no let's see
what happens to you dick you're [ __ ]
your girlfriend you look up and there's
a picture your grandmother across on the
wall yes come down as you dig a you see
a yarmulke right you think about him
Louie well how can i [ __ ] somebody I got
Hitler in my heart these are the brains
burn them up burn them up on him I'll
break down all right
I was another fun episode of the church
always happened now I'm lucky to have
you guys in my heart you have helped me
as much as I have helped you throughout
this whole ordeal I hope I helped some
of you [ __ ] you sent me messy
as you say I I've helped you drop this
but you guys have helped me more you got
me a house and not you taught me a lot
of things you told me that you paying
attention real quick let's talk about a
few things here listen like I told you
before I hate dirty balls
I hate when my ass is dirty I hate when
I scratched my nutsack and I get that
blow cream we go between your legs you
get that little thick sweat layer of
sweat there's sweat then there's like
vocal ball sweat I hate ear wax with all
my heart you understand me I stick
[ __ ] everything in my ear to get
everything open now that I got the
hearing aids I get more wax than ever
but there's some why hate one happens
when you talk to someone you can see a
piece of hair come on they're [ __ ]
those that bothers me so when I got the
[ __ ] email about this I almost died
that man
I had a new product announcement the
scientists over they have released their
first nose hair trimmer
it's called you ready for this one don't
weed wacker
now everybody's doing video calls right
now I gotta say it the only thing that
cameras picking up here are the spider
legs and they're sticking out of my
[ __ ] nose but not really because I
cleaned them off with the [ __ ] weed
whacker before I did the podcast I want
to try it out who the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with Joey [ __ ] bananas
where the [ __ ] wrote this you know I'm
tip-top Magoo I even do my [ __ ]
eyebrows I do everything cuz I got these
spider webs coming out a little [ __ ]
antennas so listen you know about mass
game I've already told you about how
they keep your ball safe when you're
trimming your [ __ ] ballsack and your
muffler now you can get the same job
done in your nose listen I took a hair
out that usually holds onto a snot up
here I had like a little head I gotta
let it grow from time to time and the
snot juice comes out of there I thought
I put that weed whacker in the I heard
that [ __ ] head died today he just
went out I just thought something in
there when you weed whacking knows
everything must [ __ ] go everything
everything I had a little pimple that
was bleeding that [ __ ] I took it
down for the [ __ ] route and when if
you got a big [ __ ] nose the weed
whacker will work for you to you it's
got its got a contoured design to fit
all [ __ ] moles you ever look at some
of these nose and go I'll never invite
that guy to a coke party that [ __ ]
listen this [ __ ] thing will work for
you the weed whacker you might think
Joey isn't this no man's problem no how
you gonna [ __ ] if you can't flip to
breathe through your nose this is
everybody's problem you got a [ __ ]
trim your nose is when they come
sticking out it's [ __ ] disgusting
now get your face looking good as your
balls with the weed whacker for manscape
okay so now you got the manscape 3.0 and
you got the [ __ ] weed whack or
whatever the lawnmower 3.0 I'm sorry and
you got the weed whacker right it's one
thing you'll put up your nose that's
good for you this is the [ __ ] thing
right here try the [ __ ] weed whacker
some [ __ ] manscape right now if you
check my Instagram I'm Monday I have
another video for you up of the [ __ ]
weed whacker cuz I love you [ __ ]
but do me a favor right now let's get
the church family back in tip-top shape
shaving their nutsack and trimming their
[ __ ] nose hairs get 20% off plus free
shipping when you press in the special
code you're ready write this down nose
pubes at manscape comm with a capital
end and a capital B that's nose pubes at
manscape calm
you'll never get a deal like this on
nose candy anywhere I'm giving you 20%
off and free shipping at manscape doc
calm with cold nose pubes capital and
capital B as my daughter says upper case
I don't know what the [ __ ] that me your
pee-pee but B what no it's not boobs
it's pubes okay your [ __ ] nose pubes
what are you waiting for go whack your
weeds right now manscape calm code nose
pubes so most importantly I want to
thank you guys for following us and
having our backs every [ __ ] week I
rent I love you guys listen January 25th
through the 27th at the Brea improv June
June 25th to the 27th at the brand prom
you got a call because sadly mad I
really had a lot of tickets sold so I
think they're only letting 200 people in
there so if you want to move your
tickets from Saturday to either Friday
or Thursday night you'll be helping us
out listen if you come on Thursday night
this would be my first time on stage
unless someone was up miraculously
before that please if you come on
Thursday night to the improv that's my
first time on stage I'm just gonna go up
there and talk some [ __ ] and put some
[ __ ] together if you want to come come
if you don't I [ __ ] get it I'm doing
a resident residency there starting in
July every two weeks so I'll be
performing there all the way to this end
I'm not traveling guys let's see what
goes on with this [ __ ] thing let's
see if we're gonna go to war let's see
if [ __ ] african-american lives matter
let's see what's gonna happen before I
start get on a plane and and I found
that something else
everything is connecting
you got on the plane you're gonna have
to connect to go this few direct [ __ ]
flights so get ready guys but anyway
I'll see you and [ __ ] it to Bray Improv
June 25th to 27th if not I'm doing a
residency there all summer and I'm
giving you $20 tickets no I'm not
looking to [ __ ] another one
just $20 entertainment Tuesday night I'm
gonna give you a great show I'm gonna
work out my new Wow which I don't have
so we're gonna work it out together so
it's even a better time all right I love
you guys have a great weekend I want to
thank the [ __ ]
I want to thank you guys and I want to
thank your families and I want to wish
you all a blessing have a great [ __ ]
weekend stay black and do your
[ __ ] thing to church what's
happened now check this [ __ ] me Olli
[Music]